good morning Hank it's Tuesday I suppose
every book I read shifts my perspective
in some way and I almost always feel
like my life is richer for having read a
book even if the book wasn't
particularly good but I rarely feel like
a single book made a lasting and
significant change in my life but this
book really has this is a gratitude
journal made by Kurtz Cassatt the people
behind those phenomenally beautiful and
informative videos you know the ones
with the birds and the breath giving
wisdom about how to go on and why they
made a video a while back about
gratitude and the evidence that a strong
sense of gratitude is good for human
health and well-being and then they
released a gratitude journal which I
promptly bought because I'm a sucker for
journals now I have a long history of
buying journals I don't actually write
in because there's this huge difference
between the person I actually am and the
person I wish to be and I continue to
believe despite all evidence that
somehow making a purchase will help me
bridge this divide but it never does
except this time it did so the book
starts out just having me notice what
happened today where I might have found
something to be thankful for and then
over time it moves from that
hypothetical to the concrete asking me
to write about what I'm grateful for
that day specifically and also in my
life more generally and then every few
pages there's information about a
scientific study about gratitude or a
reflection exercise it's a really
wonderful book and I will link to it in
the doobly-do below but I should also
note that my kids are doing gratitude
journals with me and they do their
gratitude journals in like 30 cent
notebooks which also work because the
idea is very simple every day even on
miserable days write down what you're
grateful for I've been doing this for
the last few months which of course have
not been just any few months and it
really has changed the way I feel about
human life this is partly because I now
go through the day looking for what I
might write about whatever little
moments gave me a break from the dread
for instance yesterday Alice and I
spotted a great horned owl in the
backyard and we observed its behaviors
and we researched great horned owls to
find out why they have yellow eyes and
we watched youtube videos about great
horned owls and so this morning I wrote
about how I was grateful for the
Internet at least the pleasant great
horned owl enthusiast corner of the
internet and also grateful to the owl
and grateful to have a backyard that is
apparently owl friendly so Hank like
many people my brain problems have
dramatically amplified by the wider
problems which makes it hard at times to
think straight of course I know I'm
incredibly lucky and have a lot to be
grateful for but the thing is I've been
saying that my whole life like anytime
I'd be having a miserable time of it I
would say I know I have a lot to be
grateful for but I didn't know it
because I wasn't paying attention to
what I was grateful for
I was only paying attention to what I
you're like for instance a brain that
can handle a crisis without resorting to
its worst and most dangerous habits but
just by writing for a few minutes every
day if I really focus on what I'm
thankful for I can not just know that I
have a lot to be grateful for I can feel
that I have a lot to be grateful for I
am grateful for Al's and for spring and
for safe food and water and for the
health of my family but most of all I
find myself writing about my gratitude
to other people for their generosity I'm
grateful to my kids teachers for
figuring out how to e learn with almost
no preparation but also I'm grateful to
my teachers many of them gone now
because their love and support held me
together and in some ways still holds me
together I'm grateful to my brother for
keeping things running with compassion
and determination I'm grateful to my
kids for their resilience and good humor
and I'm grateful to many strangers whose
work brings me joy and comfort from
Mohamed Salah to Mary Oliver and when I
am feeling grateful I also know that I
am not alone that the love of friends
and family even those who are far away
even those I will never see again is
still with me just as my love is still
with them and that's how I know I can
make it through one day at a time as
long as I stay on the lookout for owls
and other gifts so Thank You Kurtz cuz
out for all the wonderful videos and for
this little book which really has
changed my life and we could all use a
little change Hank I'll see you on
Friday